minimum page lengths or minimum word
counts or maybe the worst thing that
ever happened to writing classes and I
think it makes everyone a worse writer
hi I'm just some dude from the internet
that you probably should be listening to
for advice but I do a lot of writing for
my youtube channel this one not not the
one you're watching now but this one
where the good stuff goes and what I've
realized is that it's never about making
things longer and all word counts and
page minimum page length do is just make
you bloviate sentences and add a bunch
of flabby tangents that nobody cares
about why do we do this this is so
confusing when I like enter the real
world I really quickly realize that your
number one problem is not that things
aren't long enough it's always that they
are too long so why are we teaching
people that length is a virtue that
somehow it is some expression of your
effort if anything it's quite the
opposite if you can get to a point in a
very short amount of time it's often
because you've crafted that idea and
really understood it and gotten to the
essential so I wanted to say the
teachers out there to students page link
is stupid word count is stupid yes it
makes everyone do a minimum amount of
effort but that's it and it hurts real
writers who are trying to get better
because their problem is not style
usually or content their problem is that
the writing is boring and it's boring
because it's usually bloated with
unnecessary words so stop it did you
ever come Louis under the volcano yeah I
did and I own myself - [ __ ] why why
because like any other writer there's no
pace there's no quickness in his lines
each line must be an entity up to itself
it must not bore the reader the writer
it must not bore anybody you have to
have a juice in each line don't you see
you don't believe me I'm trying to tell
you